hi Alvaro I know you focus on devops and
such reliability engineering
so I have a question for you if
deploying code to serverless like Cloud
run is so simple do I even need a cicd
pipeline
hi Martin
that's a good question let's find it out
[Music]
when you start a new project you have
control for all over the project however
when this project starts to grow up it
becomes more complex for example you
might start with a monolithic
application and then go to a
microservice architecture
that's true not only can the system grow
but also the team
exactly multi-members means more changes
to take care of a cicd pipeline will
help you to manage all that complexity
and minimize that changes will block
anything on your application that's why
you need a cicd pipeline I see and what
would the csad pipeline actually do
Alvaro
okay from the moment we commit the code
to the repository until these changes
appear to the final user there are at
least some state that should be done for
example build start artifacts and
deployed ah that makes sense uh can we
set up a c ICD pipeline here to to show
all these steps sure I had this whipped
up sample from the cloud called samples
it's written in notices and I already
pushed it to my own GitHub repository so
we can use it for the pipeline cicd
great and you said node.js Alvaro what
if I want to use another programming
language there are more samples in
different languages on the cloud code
repository on GitHub you can go and find
your preferred language
all right so we have the code it's
checked out into Source control what's
next okay we got one repository for the
code and now we need another kind of
repository a repostory for artifacts
okay and what kind of artifacts what
what does it mean
an actifer
touch a library or in our case a
container image for example
in Google Cloud we have artifact
registry to sort container images
show you how can we create one
in the artifact registry section click
on the plus button to create a new
Repository
let's use node.js example for the name
and South America is one for the region
that region is located in Sao Paulo
Brazil which is to where I am
then great and save the name because
we're going to use it later
perfect we have one repository for the
code in GitHub and one repository for
the container images in Google Cloud
what's next
okay with this repositories now we can
use cloud build
is a serverless platform that allows
developers to create simple but powerful
CISD pipelines the first thing to do is
connect the Jacob repository to Cloud
build
oh I remember I did that in an earlier
video I Shot with Aaron I'll link to
that video in the description below I
will do those steps again with the
GitHub repo you just showed me I'll
borrow
in the cloud builds section I click on
connect Repository
then I select GitHub as a source
and Cloud build we'll check our GitHub
credentials
after the authentication I will select
the repository I want to connect to in
this case a hello Cloud run
perfect the repo is connected
good job now I will create a trigger
the trigger will make a start the cicd
pipeline so in the console click on
create a trigger let's put hello Glow
Run pipeline for the name and then
choose again South America is one
because it's my region
for event I choose push through a branch
to trigger the pipeline in which report
the one we just connected and let's
choose the branch main for the pipeline
so to recap we have put the code in repo
on GitHub then we connected that repo
with Cloud build and now we're telling
Cloud build to trigger the CI CD
pipeline every time we push to the main
branch on GitHub back to you Alvaro now
it's time to tell clubview what to do
during the pipeline
and this is where we Define what happens
in the build store and deploy steps that
you mentioned before right that's right
in the configuration part I choose Cloud
build configuration file
this file will be located inside the
repo as Cloud build.yaml this is a
special file as you mentioned here we
described every step we want to do in
the pipeline
at the end I just gonna click on create
so now uh you have to create this file
in the repo right
yeah
I already planted the repo on my
computer so we can create a file right
now
in the collective demo I'm going to
define the build step first
and that looks like Docker build just
like I would run on my local machine but
the syntax is a little different
actually it's the same it's just broken
in different lines we are telling cloth
wheel to run Docker build with some
arguments
um by the way the chi argument which
means the task of the container it's
pretty long this is because part of the
tag has the path to the artifact raised
repository we just created before
and why do we do that
well all the steps will run in a trusted
environment inside Cloud build so it's
harder for a bad actor to inject
malicious code into the app while
building when code build finishes its
work this environment will disappears so
the container inside will disappear too
that's why we need a repository for
images
this long tag indicates where we are
going to store the image
got it as that was the build step the
next step is a store right but didn't we
store the container already
the container image is still inside the
cloud build environment we need to store
it in a more permanent place we will use
the artificial repository for that
so in the cloud piano file we have to
add the store step this time we are
using the docker push command
we're almost done uh looks like the
final step in your list is deploy and
for that I have a great candidate we are
building container images and Cloud run
is a great way to run those in the cloud
that's correct I'm going to deploy the
application to Cloud run
so we add the gcloud command to deploy
to Cloud run in the cloud build file
with the same fields we use in the
consult
all right now that we're all set we can
commit and push the code to the repo and
if everything is right the pipeline
should start working
yep you're right
let me commit the code
push it to the branch Main and there we
go
so let's go to the cloud build console
to see what's happening uh yeah it's
working and we can see the locks here
goes the billion log the story logs and
the prologues it's done
so if we go to the link to the cloud run
service we can check the application uh
let's go
it works so the Lesser between Austin
and Portuguese
indeed and if we're making a change in
the code we only need to commit and push
the code again to GitHub and Cloud build
will do the rest but but one quick
question is there a way to make this new
release show up for only some of our
users like a canary test release
yep so clue run has this feature out of
the box let me show you how to add this
step into our pipeline
on the deployed step we can add the no
traffic flag
so no traffic will be sent to this new
list
then we can add one more step let's call
it Canary
in this step we are the update service
command to split the traffic to the
latest revision 50 of the traffic should
work for testing purposes in a real
Canal release we might use five percent
State I like that can you change the
main title on the site so it'll be
easier to see the difference between the
new and the old version
sure good idea
in the index file we can add hello from
Brazil
let's do it and then commit
and push
the pipeline started as expected and in
the cloudview console we can see this
new Canary step and all these slots
alright it's completed let me check the
app
let's refresh many times sometimes we
say hello from Brazil which is the
canary list and sometimes head overclock
run which is the old version
thank you for showing us of this it's
done Navarro uh you know I've been
typing gcloud commands manually in the
terminal to deploy my cloud run-ups I
think I may go and add cicd pipelines
for them now
I'm glad to hear that Martin when you
automate building unemployment steps
with a cicd pipeline you will free up
time so you can focus more on new
features
yes I want to spend less time with the
infrastructure and more time adding
features my users actually asked for
thank you everyone for watching you will
find links to the repos and tools we
talked about in the show notes if you
have any questions for Alvaro or me or
suggestions for future serverless topics
please enter them in the comments below
we read every single comment
until next time
[Music]